be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so with many fans claiming to have seen
eternity in the ant-man film and with
director Peyton Reed stating that this
is one of the many possibilities what I
want to do here is have a discussion on
his character and what I'm hoping is
that by the end of this video you'll
have a better understanding of his role
in the Marvel Universe and more
importantly why the appearance of
Eternity is such a big deal
so because I can't find any information
for why it was that eternity was made I
decided that I would throw my opinion in
here with regards to his creation
created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby and
initially appearing in strange tales
issue number 138 in September of 1965
eternity was the first being introduced
in Marvel Comics as a cosmic entity
while the stranger did appear a few
months prior and seemed to exist on a
cosmic level his initial introduction
came with no information regarding his
purpose or role in Marvel Comics aside
from collecting powerful individuals for
study because the strange tales series
was away from Marvel to introduce Doctor
Strange and by extension delve into
Eastern culture and concepts of
mysticism and with the Silver Age of
comics rapidly expanding the lineup of
earthbound characters like Captain
America Iron Man and spider-man the
stories of Doctor Strange provided
Marvel with the best outlet regarding
the introduction of strange and
interesting concepts as well as
expanding on the Marvel Universe beyond
the planet Earth in addition to this
when looking back at Marvel's
introduction of heroes villains and a
multitude of concepts a kind of
organization is always established in
terms of groups who belongs and doesn't
belong to those groups and the purpose
at all things serve as an example all
mutants are either part of the x-men or
in some capacity consistently deal with
the x-men take for example the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants or factor 3
both of which exists as allies and
enemies to the x-men team conversely the
purpose of mutants in relation to us as
the reader is how they cope with a
struggle of various forms of oppression
at the hands of religious groups hate
groups and even the federal government
not mutant beings with superpowers
follow the same pattern encompassing the
Avengers or some variation there and
like the defenders and deal with their
own issues ranging from global threats
to humanitarian efforts with this in
mind it would stand to reason that if
model was going to introduce a pantheon
of cosmic beings these de facto gods
would have to have a ranking system of
most powerful two least powerful have
some measure of relatability and serve a
purpose in and of themselves and to this
end eternity exists as the most powerful
cosmic entity in the Marvel Universe
with a different version existing in
each of the universes of Marvel's
multiverse representing all that
encompasses the universe
from individuals to planets to galaxies
and everything in between
eternity also represents the passage of
time from the point the universe came
into existence to the point at which it
would meet its end whenever that
happened to be as a byproduct of this
while each version of eternity and the
respective universe has incredible power
they're actually a result of their own
universes formation what this means is
that with the Infinity Gauntlet ability
to control all facets of the universe
for example this means that the person
wielding the Infinity Gauntlet has the
ability to over power and control
eternity itself let's think about it
this way if the universe is a glass of
water
eternity represents the water in the
glass a person wielding the Infinity
Gauntlet can manipulate that glass of
water by changing its shape a limiting
part of it or in some capacity
manipulating it so Mormon does it make
it easy for us to decipher the origin of
eternity in the mainstream Marvel
Universe because there is no singular
story of how everything came into
existence what we're going to have to do
here is delve into different stories
from different characters starting with
Adventures of the x-men issue number 12
Marvel establishes that all the
characters that exists in the current
reality referred to as earth-616 existed
and the previous reality designated or
zero what we're not given an in-depth
explanation of what this continuity was
like what we are told is that at some
point a being called the dweller and
darkness a demon that fed off the fear
of others created a fracture in the
m'kraan crystal the Nexus of all
realities in the multiverse with the
energy is expanding an uncontrollable
raid and knowing that this would lead to
the destruction of the earth zero
continuity the dweller and darkness
sought to feed on the fear of the
inhabitants with the ending of the
universe in order to be born into the
earth-616 universe with absolute power
and effort to keep this from happening
but with the destruction of the universe
unavoidable the Phoenix force of earth
zero bound all minds together in peace
rendering the dweller and darkness
completely powerless
from here we jump to the Mighty Thor
Volume one issue number 169 what we're
told is that at the same time that the
dweller and darkness was being defeated
a bee named Galan was attending
discover the reason for why the Earth's
serial continuity was ending while Galan
had attributed its destruction to a
force he couldn't identify or comprehend
and with the universe collapsing in on
itself as Thanos volume 1 issue number 3
tells us that the Earth's zero version
of eternity placed gallon in a cocoon of
sorts that allowed him to be reborn into
earth-616 once the ending of the earth 0
continuity completed and the earth-616
universe came into existence all of this
reality was formed and with it came both
Galactus as well as eternity the
embodiment of all there is
so as a representation of the universe
itself
eternity is an essential part of the
Marvel cosmology while a hands-on
approach almost never happens
events like Infinity Gauntlet require
eternity to act since the survival of
the universe itself was perceived to be
at stake however from time to time
eternity will act on behalf of
individuals even when the outcome has no
detrimental effect on the universe as an
example during the trial of Reed
Richards and Fantastic Four issue number
260 to Galactus had previously helped
the Fantastic Four defeat a being named
hare ax and drained of his energies and
nearly starving REE provided Galactus
with the sustenance necessary to live
the result was that because Galactus
consumes worlds has killed billions of
people and will continue to do so Reed
is put on trial for allowing Galactus to
live appearing in order to provide those
involved with an understanding of how
the universe works
eternity provides everyone with cosmic
awareness allowing them to realize that
Galactus is an intricate part of the
universe itself and that his existence
is a necessity regardless of the number
of people that he kills now in terms of
the Marvel films we know that you trying
to be was one of the beings responsible
for creating the Infinity stones as was
explained in guardians of the galaxy the
suspected appearance of eternity and
ant-man provides us with a couple of
important facts the first is that Thanos
as possession of the Infinity Gauntlet
would have universe wide affects and the
second is that it establishes a much
larger continuity involving the macro
verse and possibly even the Living
Tribunal with that being said we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I
will catch you guys later peace